あの今日のテーマは あの
それほど難しいテーマではございません
難しくしようとすればいくらでもできますけど
できるだけ簡単なところをお話しいたします
えーと このまず仏教といって
我々は何をしているんでしょうか
ということは 今の社会状況から考えても知っておいた方がいいんです
世の中の人間というのは
もう何か主義を持ってるんですね
何か頭の中で何か考え方を持っていて
その通りに行こう 生きて生きようとする
そこまで勝手でいいんです
自分が何か考えて その通りに生きていると
それまでみんな自由だからね
構いません でも 自分が何か意見
何か考え方 何か主義を持っちゃうと
すぐ思い浮かぶのは他の人と間違ってるんだよ
私と違いますよ 私と違いますよと
人のことを考えること自体が大きなお世話なんですね
自分一人でどんな主義を持ったっても
それは一向に構いません
でも 他の人々は私と同じ意見ではありませんと
私と同じ生き方をしていないんだと
と思うところから まる大きなお世話で人の自由を奪っているんです
自分に何か意見を持って生きている自由あるならば
すべての人々にも自分なりの主義やら生き方やら持って生きていられる自由があるんですね
人間というのは基本的にそこら辺間違っちゃうんです
例えば 宗教の世界で人が桜の木を拝んでも
ブナの木を拝んでも もう勝手でいいんですよ
それで お犬様を拝んでも
お猫様を拝んでも もう勝手でいいんじゃないんですかね
でも お猫様を拝んでる人が
お犬様を拝んでる人が間違ってるんだと
犬で違いますよと というのはおかしいんです
そこで他人が自分と違うと間違っているんだと思ったところで
もう他人に対し差別感が生まれてきて
狂暴な人だったら できるだけの人を自分の考え方に
自分の生き方に入れ込めようとする
それでとことん人間の自由というものはなくなっていくんですよ
人の自由を奪って奪っていく途中で
まあいろんな相手に対して迷惑をかけたり
悪いことをしたり 批判非難したり
そういうことはとことん起きていくんですね
それで非難して 侮辱して
罵倒して気が済まない時は手も足も出ますね
人に対して そういうことで
何か主義を持つこと自体で
それで止まらないで もうちょっと余計なことを考えることから
もう世界の人間に自分
自分に生きていられる自由というものは奪われて
失われてなくなってしまう
結果としてはもう大量の人殺し
もう残酷な残酷な行為
差別感 不公平なこと 戦争
そういうことが最終的な結果になるです
なるんです でも 誰一人も何か主義を持って生きているのは
あくまでも幸福になるためなんですね
私はこの考え方で幸せだと
自分の何か苦しみがあって
何か問題があって 自分には何か不安があって
何か主義を持つ それは宗教的でなくてもいいんですよ
例えば 私は共産主義だよという方々は
自分の幸せは この共産主義という生き方から得られるものやと思うんで
それで構いません 私は資本主義やという人が
資本主義社会でなかったら自分が幸せになるんだと思ってるんですよ
それだけでは それではいいんですよ
別に でも相手が資本主義じゃないんだと
この野郎と思うところはどうでしょうかと
相手が共産主義ではありませんと
なんとかして自分の主義に入れなくちゃいけないと思うところから人間が間違っているんです
そこからすべての世界には苦しみしか結果として残らないんです
苦しみしか残らない 願っていた幸せ
それが壊れるんです たった一つのことを希望して願っているんですけど
そのものがなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから金儲かりたいと言って
その結果としてホームレスになるならば
その人の生き方は正しいと言えますか？お金がない人は金儲かりたいと何か行動して
その結果として金持ちになったとするならば
その人の道が正しいんでしょうに
もっと金儲かりたいと思って持っていたものもなくなって
最終的には何一つもなくなっちゃってホームレスになるならば
その道が間違っているんです
ですから 幸せを願って
幸福を願って 安心感を願って
心の安らぎを願って 何かを生き方をする
何かを主義を持って生活すると
その結果として肝心な幸福
幸せも失ってしまうならば
気をつけた方がいいと
ですから 仏教の立場というのははっきりして
主義を持つ持たないことなんですよ
何も主義を持たないと
自分の心というのはすごく自由を味わっちゃうんですよ
ものすごく自由を味わっちゃいます
そこでどんな人とも仲良く生活することもできます
どんな人を差別することもできなくなります
でも 主義を持たないことは私の主義だよと言っちゃうと
それは主義になっちゃうんですね
そこは気をつけないと
そういう人とも一回話がありましたから
私と 自分が何も主義を持てないんだと言いかってはくるんだけど
結局はまあ私の反論でまあまあうまくいかなかったんですね
まあそういうことで この世の中っていうのは
この政治的考え方から戦争
不幸などが生まれているんです
経済的な考え方から貧困だけ増え
増えていくんですね 搾取と貧困
宗教的な思考から人殺しと
それは昨日起きた出来事ではありません
私は今日考えているのは
人間というのはもう宗教思考というのを始めたその時から
もう他を差別することをやってきたのではないかと
だから宗教歴史っていうのは結局はっきり言うと
血の歴史なんですよ 涙の歴史なんです
虐待の歴史なんです そんな無意味な何かの信仰のおかげで
人類の文化始めてからどれほど人を苦しんだかと
どれほどの人を死んだかと
どれほどの人々が精神的に悩んだり
差別主観で苦しんだりしたかというと
限りないんですよ だから目覚めなさいと
物事をはっきり見なさいと
余計な主観で 余計な感情で
この事実を何といいますか
このねじ曲げることをしないではっきり見てみなさいと
だから目覚めなさいというのは仏教なんです
何か信じなさいではなくて
目覚めて世を見なさいと
自分を見なさいと どんな世界か
自分が何者かと そうするとはっきりと見えるでしょうと
だからしっかり見る 見てみて理解していく道と
何かを信じて もう何もかもその信仰に合わせて
その主義に合わせて生きる道と比べると
どちらが自然かというと
すべてのものは見て理解していく道がすごく自然で平和なんですね
わざと強引に見える事実さえねじ曲げてねじ曲げて
自分の思想に変えて変えていく道っていうのは
それ自体束縛で束縛であって
人間には大変苦しみということに結果としてなってしまいますね
そういうわけで あの まあ仏教といって
別に何か主義を教えているわけじゃないんです
何か変な信仰を教えているわけじゃないんです
皆様方の自由を奪っているわけじゃないんです
今とっくに自由がない
今とっくに苦しんでいる
今 いろんな考え方で いろんな文化的な思考で
歴史的な思考で 感情で
好みで足引っ張られている
束縛されている 手足 足
首 もうどちらかでももうもうもう鎖で繋げているんです
それは一つ一つ破って自由にするために
ブッダが目覚めの道を教えたんですね
では エウェーカニン まあ悟りにはエウェーカニンと英語で言うんですけどね
ウェイク 目覚めなさい
起きなさい そういうことだから
この 人間 やっぱりどう見ても自由でなければいけないし
それはまあ体は自由になりませんだけど
やっぱり我々は心を自由にすることはできるんですね
体っていうのは地球からもう借りたもんだから
これは地球の法則によって動いているんですね
それはどうにもならないんですね
そういうわけで すぐ即座に人々に心を自由にする道をお釈迦様が教えているんです
今 皆様が実践した生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
その一行だけでも この世の中の人間理解するならば
これどれほど智慧の教えかと
どんな角度で考えたっても
それが正しいと見えるはずなんですね
私に生きる権利あるならば
皆に生きる権利あるんだよと
私が生きていきたければ生きていきたいと思うんでしょうに
それはもう実感あるでしょうに
であるならば もうたとえ小さな目に見えぬ生命にさえにも生きていきたいという気持ちは持っていると
これははっきりと誰でもわかっていることでしょうに
いろんな宗教で動物なんかは殺して食べてもいいやと言ってますけど
食べるために作っているんだそうとかね
その時私はもうすごい反論するんですよ
豚が食べるために生きている動物やと思うなら
なんで豚逃げるんですかね
殺す時は なんで鶏は逃げようとしてるんですかね
やっぱり一つ一つの生命が自分で死にたくないという気持ちを持ってるんでしょ
はっきりしているんですね
そのはっきりしている事実を否定して
生きる権利我のみにありと
言うと それはもう無知もものすごい大変な
もうひどい状態 極端な状態なんですね
だから 世界にあるこの一切のこの苦しみを作るすべての思考に対して
お釈迦様はたった一行で
サッベーサッターバワンドスキタッタ
すべての生命が幸福でありますように
その一行でお釈迦様の答えがあるんです
それは感情的な表現ではありません
だからかっこいいことを言おうではないかとおっしゃったわけじゃないんです
その中にものすごい深い智慧があるんです
目覚めた智慧があるんです
生命のことを観察してみると
顕微鏡で小さな微生物でも観察してみると
一生懸命生きていようと頑張っているんですね
まあ二 三もうもう二 三秒で死んでもう湧けると
微生物なんかはね みるみるうちに分離
分解して分解というんですか
分裂して別々な生命になる
それも死なんですけど
前にいた細胞が死んで新しい細胞が二つ現れる
あの体の材料は同じだから同じ生命が
例えばアメーバは同じく生きているんだというアメーバは永久的に生きていることになりますよ
だって 分離して分離していくんで
そんなことはないんです
一旦細胞分裂が起きたら新しい生命なんです
だからそちらの生と死がはっきりあるんです
だから そういう世界を見ても
やっぱり一生懸命生きていようとは努力しているんですね
それで我々は何か主観を持って
何か主義を持って 自分だけの殻を作らないで
自分だけ閉じこもれる檻を作らないで
すべての生命は全く同じ平らで同じだと
空気の空気のように 空気っていうのはたった一つ
一個ではないでしょうに
分子ですか？モレキュールですか
一個一個の空気が別々にもうあるんでしょうね
でも全部一つになっているでしょうね
海の水だったら一滴一滴取ることはできますけど
でもどんな一滴でも同じ水なんです
同じ塩水なんです 生命を見ると
それはその真理をはっきりと
そんな深い知識なくてもわかるはずなんです
なぜそれがわからないかというと
我々の頭がものすごく汚れているんです
憎しみで 怒りで エゴで
ものすごく汚れているんです
だから見えないだけ 我々に何を教えてくれるかと
学校などに行ったら 社会と学校が心を汚すだけ
余計な態度を作ってくれる
あんたは偉大なる人間だとかね
何々人だからすごいやとかね
それだけでも間違っていて恐ろしい考え方なんです
だからどんな民族もすごい自分の民族に対して態度を持ってるでしょうに
結果はどうですかね 他人を殺そうとする
他民族を殺そうとする
それでやがて自分の民族さえもものすごい苦しみを味わっちゃいますね
現代社会でいえば 江戸系の方々は自分たちがすごい偉いと思っていて
他はもう関係ないやとと思っていていくことで
本当に頭も良くて 経済能力もあるで
政治的な能力もあって
もう何の問題もなく幸せに生きていられるはずなんですけど
あの思考のおかげで怯えて生活しなくちゃいけない
苦しみながら生活しなくちゃいけない
なのに なんで我々のような
こんなに頭も良くて活動もできて
もうなかなかいろんなことできるのに
なんでそんなに安定して平和で生きていられないかという
その変なへんてこりんな思考に基づいて生活しているんだからなんです
それで皆様方はすごいありがたがって歴史なんか勉強しているでしょうに
歴史っていうのはほとんど嘘を書いてるもんですよ
私は何回もこちらでも言いましたからね
一般人の生き方は全然書いてないんでしょうに
農民の生き方とかね 百姓さんの生き方とか
例えば 今 日本の 2001年の歴史書こうと思って
皇室のことだけ書くと
日本人にどんな関係ありますかね
その人々は何時に起きるかとかね
何を食べているかとかね
誰が誰と結婚しているかとか
いつ即位儀礼を行ったか
いつ結婚したかとかね
そんなことを明確に書いてあっても
それが日本の 2001年の日本の歴史ですかね
だから長い間の変化を歴史で書いているんだから
それだけ書いてるんですよ
誰がさんが有名な人なんです
歴史っていうのは勝利者だけの出来事だと
だから我々はそういうものを勉強して
自分の人生を設計する
生き方を決める 自分の自分個人の主義を作る
それだけで大変危険人物になってしまうんですね
だから世の中のどんな学問
どんな教え どんな何にしたっても
人間は恐ろしい人物として再構成するためにできているものなんです
ですから ブッダが目に見えてるんだから
苦しんでいること 目に見えてるんだから
人をお互いに殺し合いやってること
同じ家族 同じ兄弟にしたって
お互いに憎しみ合ったりしているんだから
これ何のせい？いろんなことを教えてくれるせいでしょうに
兄弟でもお互いに憎しみ合うのは
例えば一人の子がもう学校の勉強は上手にできると
2番目の子は全く興味ないと
それで兄弟喧嘩する必要ないんです
でも 親やら社会やらね
お前が頭がいい お前が頭が悪い
そうすると その兄弟の間で差別感が生まれてくるんですよ
頭がいいのはいい子やと
頭が悪いのは悪い子やと言ったら
ああ 兄貴がいい子で 俺が悪い子やと
という気持ちが生まれちゃうでしょうに
そういうことになってくると
同じ兄弟でもお互いに憎しみことになってしまうんですね
だから何一つもこの世の中で残念なことにないんですね
平等を語る 無制限に無差別を語る教え
生き方っていうのは だから人間がそういうまあ仏教を使っている言葉っていうのは
無制限というか無料というかね
限りなく広げる まあ制限とにかくない思考
生命に対してもって生活しなくちゃいけないんですね
それが発見して教えたのはお釈迦様だから
仏教と呼んであって お釈迦様がこういうので
こんなものは誰にでも発見できますよと
明らかな事実だから わざわざとあの湾曲させた教えではないんだから
これは誰にでもわかることでしょうと
ですから 仏教と仏教といっても
全く他の宗教と全く別な
もう他人が仏教ではない一教徒だと
だから違うんだという考え方は成り立たないんです
本当の仏教徒であるならば
まあそれはまあ仏教でお釈迦様は名前はゴータマであって
全然ゴータマ教と言ってないんですよ
それ見たってわかるでしょうに
これはゴータマの教えですよと
それはゴータマ教じゃなくて仏教なんですよ
目覚めの道なんですね
なぜお釈迦様は自分のことをブッダと言ったんでしょうかというと
個人ということを消しちゃったんです
ブッダというならば 誰でもブッダになれるんです
だから私は田中ですよという言葉と
私は人間ですよという言葉とを比べてみてください
私は田中です 田中一郎ですよと言ったら
たった一人だけの人間なんです
一人だけの生命なんです
人間ですと言った途端
この個人的な存在というのは消えちゃうでしょうに
もう多数の生命の一個だけになるんです
だからお釈迦様は自分の教えはゴータマ教ではなくて
仏教にしたんです 悟り開いてから目覚めてからは
自分がゴータマ ゴータマと
時々他人がゴータマと呼ばれたことはありますけど
ブッダは自分のことはブッダという言葉を使うし
如来という言葉を使うんですね
お釈迦様が選んだのは如来
タタハガタという言葉なんですね
そのタタハガタという言葉はもっと謙虚的なんですね
いわゆるありのままのことはちょっとわかりましたと
ちょっとではなくて ありのままの状況をわかった人という意味で
タタハガタと いわゆる至るべき位置にもう至ったと
そういうことを言うと
皆様にも教えてあげることもできるし
みんなに安心してブッダの教えを聞くこともできるし
自分が成功してから他人に教えたんですね
で そういうふうな思考こそ
やっぱり人間の幸福に至る
人間のお互いに憎しみ合うことはすぐ即座に消える
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにということを考えちゃうと
それ なんで幸せでありますようにとしたんでしょうかね
すべての生命は平等であるとか教えないで
そこら辺にもお釈迦様の智慧が見えてくるんです
すべての生命は平等であると言ったっても
誰 何をと聞いたらどうしますか
どうすることもできなくなっちゃいますね
ですから すべての生命は平等であるということは
あまり意味のない言葉
真理かもしれませんだけど
我々にとって だからお釈迦様
だから何をではなくて
幸福でありますようにと
我々には生き方を教えているんですね
それが人間の人生設計するときの基本なんですね
だから我々は何をしても
どんな生き方をしたっても
その基本的に そのすべての生命が幸福でありますようにということを
もう絶対的な条件で 絶対自分で破ることを犯すことのできない条件として生きていなくちゃいけないんです
家を建てても同じ考え方で
畑を作っても同じ思考で
工場を作っても同じ思考で
すべての生命が幸福でありますように
だから世の中にはたくさんの教えはいりません
たったその一行で生きているならば
自然はどうやって守るか
エコロジーはどうするかどうかね
もう何て言いますか 絶滅の危機に襲われている動物のことをどうやって何するのかどうかね
そんな問題は一つも出てこないでしょうに
何とか国と何とか国の問題はどうしますかとかね
何一つ成り立ちませんよ
我々は一つ国境とかなんとか国境線を作る時も
そちらにあるのは怒りですよ
憎しみですね お釈迦様の教えには
地球には戦線 国境はいりません
人はどこに住んでいたってもいいんじゃないんですか
そこでわざと同じ民族の間でも国境線を引いて互いに憎しみ合う
だから私は聞きたい質問は
お互いに憎しみ合う お互いに殺し合う思考に基づいて生きているか
あるいはすぐ瞬時に 今から心の平和
幸せ 安らぎを体験できる
この短い人生 何の苦しみもなく生きていられる道を選ぶかということなんです
悪いことに ブッダの教えにだけみんなケチつけようとする
毛ぶたがるというか なんかすごい気持ち悪がったりして
それは冗談じゃないと言いたいんだけど
まあ丁寧にしゃべらなくちゃいけないんだから
一応あまりそういう人々にあまり激しいことを言わないんだけど
本当によく言うんですね
自分たちが幸福かと聞きたいんですよ
何か偉い 何か考え方で持っているんでしょうかと
ただ 何一つわからない頭ごちゃごちゃ状態で
なんか頭なんかもうなんかトラックなんかに潰された状態で
何一つもろくに考えられないんだから
もうケチでもつけてやろうと
まあ私はもう本当はどんな反論でも相手にしたいんだけど
相手にならないんですね
そういうわけで 今日のテーマはそういうテーマなんです
すぐ即効性あるんだと
ブッダの教えは 目の前で効き目がないと信頼できません
ものすごい将来 世紀末とかね
なんとか終わってから
最後の審判が来てから
あんた方は幸せになるそうと
言うとちょっと どうかなと
言ってる本人にも自信がないではないかと
なんで延期するんですかね？なんでそれ確かめること全くできないところまで延期するんですかね
地球のもう世紀末というか
この最後の世紀末どうか分かりませんだけど
いろいろな宗教でいろいろなことを使ってますけどね
まあ破滅の時期と それになってくると
もう我々ではないでしょうに
その時は別な人間だから
問題は私たちの将来はどうなるかということなんです
孫の将来どうなるかということでもないんです
ひ孫 ひ孫の将来はどうなるんでしょうかということじゃないんです
ですから やっぱりブッダの教えの特色は即効性
すぐドーンとその瞬間で効いてほしいと
結果は だから今の世の中
ものすごい混乱状態で
いろんな人がいろんな考え方をむちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃでしょうに
しっかりしたことって誰一人も言えない
でも 仏教を聞いてみてください
すぐきちんとしたことはいつでも持っているんですね
で 実践してみれば その日から幸せになるんです
ですから 今というのは本当にもう世の中というのは主義のせいで
もう二度となかったぐらいの
二度とではなくて 一度も歴史でなかったぐらいの危機に襲われているんですよ
これが戦争になるんだと言いながら
戦争の火種を引き起こそうとしている
戦争になるんだぞということをわかっているんだったら
そうならないようなことをしてほしいんだけど
でもそんな能力はない
そんな智慧がないんですね
もしちょっと間違ったらどうなるかわからない状態なんですね
だから それぐらい危険はなぜ生まれるかと
昨日誰かがテレビで言ったんですけども
いくらアメリカが頑張ってもアフガンを倒すことはできませんと
これもう長い戦争になったら
もう必ずもうアメリカの人がアフガン人の大素振りになってしまいますよと
それは誰でもわかっている可能性あるし
それでそれはもう世界に広げて
お互いに憎しみ合うようになる恐れっていうのはもう明確にもあるし
なのにその火種を どんどん増えようとしていますね
だから私たちは全く関係ない立場からね
見てほしいんですよ なんでそんなに危機になったんでしょうかというと
それは過去人々が私の生き方こそ正しいと思っているだからなんです
被害に遭ったアメリカでも同じ思考でしょうし
被害を起こしたという人々もと同じ思考でしょうし
だからこのとにかく何かの思考に縛りつくと
もう恐ろしい結果になるんですよ
今 人に不幸 作ろうと思っているのは
イスラム教なんですけど
昔は別な宗教もよく頑張ったんですね
人殺しに だから平和な教えだ
平和な教えだと言いながら
平和な教えだったら 一人の人も裁くことをできないはずなんですよ
だから教え自体 明確に目覚めて言っているわけじゃないんです
感情で言ってるんです
我々は平和ないい人間やと
どんなアホでもそう思ってますよ
私こそ正しいやと 私が正しくないと思っている人がいますかね
世の中で 極悪を起こす犯罪者でも
だってしょうがないでしょうに
そうやるしかないやと言って
自分をディフェンディング弁解するでしょうに
だから最悪人でも自分が正しいと思っているんです
だから自分が正しいという思考っていうのは
それ自体おかしいと我々は仏教の立場から言いたいんですね
だから その思想 思想的な間違い
いわゆる単純論理の間違いなんですよ
名前を言うのは大変失礼だと思いますけど
その間違いっていうのはもう各宗教にあるんですね
キリスト教にしたっても
ユダヤ教にしたっても
イスラム教にしたっても
ヒンドゥー教にしたっても
その単純論理の間違いっていうのはあるんですね
私たちが正しいんだと
だからお前こそ正しいやで言うなよと
と私たちが言いたいんですよ
そんなものには理屈にならないんだと
だって私が正しい 次の日も正しいと
もう一人だけ私も正しいと言っちゃうと
でも生き方は客観的に見ると
3つの生き方でしょうに
だからそれで否定しているでしょうに
だからこれ単純論理でもう否定されています
で 結果としてもう大変恐ろしい
そこでこのイスラム教について
このイスラム教というのは
まあ機嫌を取るために言うんですよ
大変平和な宗教やと だからイスラム教は悪くないんだと
過激派が悪いんだと と言っても
私は単純論理で考えるんで
過激派を作ったのはどんな思想ですかと
過激派が破壊的な行動に行ってもよろしいやと
聖戦という言葉があったのはどんな経典ですかね
イスラムの人々はキリスト教の聖書を読んで戦ってもいいと
じゃあ戦おうと思っているんですかね
自分の宗教の本読んでそういうことしてるんではないか
だから口先で平和平和と言っても
明確に生き方を見てほしいんですね
キリスト教も同じことなんですよ
イエス様のことは平和の何とか王子様とか何とか言いますけど
実際にその教えを研究する方々
その専門家たちの生き方は何なのかと見ると
イエス様は全然悪いことをしていなかったんだけど
イエス様は別にね 誰にもそういう被害を起こすことはしなかったし
それは明確にあるようですけど
許せなさいということは言ってあったんだけど
その教え全体を見てみると
そうじゃないんですね
憎しみがあるんですよ
だから宗教家たちが 神学者たちが勉強して
イエス様 ちょっとあっち行ってくださいと
ちょっと休んでくださいと言っても
狂暴な態度をとる だからまあ何かこの証拠のない教えを出すと
世の中の人間に すぐそちらにあるのは苦しみの世界なんですね
だからこれから我々は思い存分味わうでしょう
その苦しみの世界っていうのは
だから私は本当に悲しいんですよ
そんな長い時間が生きているわけでもないし
我々はほんの瞬間しかね
生きていられることはできないし
その間でなんで苦しみつつあるんですかね
この短い時間で なんで泣いて生きているんですかね
泣いて泣いて生きて どう何の意味があるんですかね
私たちにはもうもう だからお釈迦様はあなた方には十分悩みあるでしょうにと
余計なことに悩むな だって年取るでしょうに
若さが消えていくでしょうに
体が弱くなるでしょうに
どんどん病気になるでしょうに
それで ああ 楽しい病気になったとか言って手を挙げて踊れますかね
体が病気になるとものすごいきつくて
薬も効かないでしょうに
年取ることには薬もないし
そこで自分が大事に愛している母親が死んでしまうわ
父親が死んでしまうわ
それで日々食べ物を得ることも大変苦しいし
ですから 我々には十分心配すること
悩むことあるにも関わらず
これ何なのかと そんな暇が余裕があるんですか？だからお釈迦様はものすごい具体的に
あんた方には苦しみがあると
その戦争の苦しみ言ってないんです
どんな豊かな国で どんな美しい体で
どんな裕福な家庭ででも
人間に生まれたならば
もう十分もう苦しみがそこにもうセットされているんですよ
だからそれ心配しなさいよと
その教えから見ても 自分のことを心配する
自分が年取っていく 仕事をしなくちゃいけない
仕事も大変難しい 収入があってもほとんど足らないぐらい
子供たちにはもっとちょっともっと楽にしてあげたいとかね
奥さんにはもうちょっと楽にしてあげたいとかね
もっときれいな服を着させてあげたいとかね
気持ちはあるんだけど
なかなか大変なんですね
だからそこら辺で自分の人生を考えてみなさいよ
そうすると他人のことに
あいつは間違っているんだよとか
なんとかとかね いう暇がないはずなんですよ
そういう人々は 自分のこの短い人生で
どのように幸せに幸福に生きていられるかということをはっきり発見するはずなんです
他人に迷惑をかけたら
ものすごい大きな もうとんでもない迷惑でしょうに
自分呼んでいただいた迷惑でしょうに
これは日本語も言葉さえ You asked for it という英語の言葉がありますけどもね
自分がまあお願いして呼んで苦しみいただくような感じで
だから我々は自分のことを心配するならば
もう人に迷惑をかける暇がない
かけちゃうと そこで大きなもう余計な苦しみが返ってくるんだから
そうすると 各人が自分の心の豊かさのために
自分の安らぎのために頑張るでしょうに
ですから ブッダの教えに基づいて
かすかにでも人に迷惑をかけることはできません
人を裁くことはできません
仏教では裁くという概念さえもないんです
ジャッジメント 裁くという
まあパーリ語で言葉はありますけど
そのジャッジメントをパーリ語で使ってミニッチェダンマ
という言葉なんですけど
それはもうちゃんと法律的に
法律的な裁判 何か問題が起きたら
その時どちらが正しいかという判断であって
自分の生命としての自分の判断というのはないんです
そういう言葉は 皆さんはよく知っている自業自得という言葉がありますね
それは明らかに仏教の言葉で
自業自得だから判断いらんでしょうに
自分が蒔いたものは自分で刈り取る
別に誰かが判断決める必要ないでしょうに
私がもみを蒔いたところで
誰かさんが来て 君もみを蒔いたんだから
もう刈り取ってもいいやと
大きな嘘で そんな言葉
だから私が間違った思考で生きていると
当然のことに私が不幸になる
私は正しい清らかな思考で生きていると
当然のことに私が幸福になる
ですから 何の悪いこともしていない
ある国民が全く純粋な悪人にやられたということはありえないんです
悪 不幸というのは自分で呼ぶんです
来てちょうだいと だから
この世界の今あるこの不安定な状態は
善と悪との戦いではありません
正と邪の戦いではありません
これは邪と邪の戦いで
悪と悪との戦いなんです
言葉で何言ったっても
だってどう考えたっても
正がもう善が悪と戦いませんよ
善人が悪人と戦いません
戦った時点で悪人だから
だから単純論理でも理解してほしいんですよ
人類が 偉そうなことをしゃべるんだけど
哲学書はいくらあるかというと
西洋世界ではもう５回建物にあったっても
もう入りきれないぐらいあるでしょうに
でも単純に論理さえ持ってないんですから
善人が武装して悪と戦うというと
何善人ですかね だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
悪は悪で倒れるんだと
悪人が自分の行為で自己破壊になるんだと
だから放っておけと 余計なことをする必要ないんです
一人一人の人間にそんな余計なことをする権利はないんです
我々のある権利はたった一つ
他人の幸せのために行動する
それは可能です 他人はそれを迷惑やとも思わない
なぜならば 他も幸せになりたい
多も笑って生活したい
自分だけではなくて 他人も楽に生きていきたい
自分だけじゃないんですね
それは他人は希望しているんですよ
そういう こういう私でもみんな協力していただければありがたいと思ってはいるんです
今もとっくに皆様方一生懸命協力してくれる
それはすごく私はものすごいありがたいと感じているんです
なんてありがたいですかと
この方々は自分の暇も全部潰して
どれほど苦労して協力してくれるかと
仏教活動のために だからどんな人でも協力してくれという気持ちはあるんですよ
それで私が協力してくれというんだから
私に誰か協力することは
私にとって迷惑とかね
ということにはならないんですよ
ですから 我々にできる仕事というのはたった一つ
他人のために 他の幸せのために
平和のために行動すること
裁く権利は誰一人もない
戦うという概念さえ成り立たない
悪は悪で滅びる 善は善で幸福になる
そういうものは普遍的な真理なんです
故に これはもうちょっとプラスアルファで言わなくちゃいけないんですけど
故に仏教では一神は成り立たないんです
すべてのものを審判する
ヤクザの親分が成り立たないんです
だって善は善で幸福になるんだから
誰かいじる必要ないでしょうに
悪は悪で滅びるんだから
例えば皆様方は毎日毎日もう 60本ぐらいタバコ吸うとしましょう
そうすると私のせいでがんになりますか？あるいは政府のせいでがんになりますか？あるいはタバコ工場のせいでがんになりますか
自分が吸ったせいでしょうに
だから自分の声で自分が滅びるんですよ
あれ アメリカでこのね
もうトバコインダストリーというか
タバコ産業からものすごいお金取ったんですね
タバコを吸った人々が癌になったなったんだよと
屁理屈ですよ なんで吸ったんですかね
もう なんて言います 間接的な場合は訴えてもいいんです
間接的にタバコ吸ってしまう場合ありますね
その場合は その人々は私たち被害者だと
あんたは空気汚染したんだと言って訴えたってもいいんだけど
ですから まあちょっと大げさな言い方なんですけど
麻薬を持ち運ぶ禁止とかね
そんな法律を作る必要ないんです
使うなよと 使ったならば勝手に死んでしまえと
こちらのせいじゃないだと
でも本当は麻薬の原材料っていうのは
昔から世の中にあったもので
いろんなその成分っていうのは
体いろいろ病気治すためとかね
使ってあったんですよ
例えばインドのアユルヴェーダの場合でも
ものすごい厳密にこれ調整して調合していろいろ薬などに使っていたんです
それは麻薬機能は全くなかったんです
例えばアユルヴェーダは手術とかほとんどしないんだから
例えば心臓発作なんか起こしたらどうしますかね
ものすごくすぐ血液が流れるようにしてあげる薬などなどありましたけど
今はない 作れません だって悪用しているんだから
栽培も禁止 まあだから世の中のものを潰すということ自体
また一つ仏教から見れば非論理的なんですね
問題は自分にあるんだよと
いっぱいここに酒があっても
もう酒があったんだから飲んでしまったよと
だからアル中になったよというのはとんでもない話であって
なんで飲んだんですかね
飲んだのは自分を誘惑されたと
あんたが弱い それでお釈迦様
じゃあ強くなる方法を教えますよと
でお釈迦様はタバコ産業も潰せとかね
イスラム教の国でそういうするんですよ
タバコとか酒とかね 持っていって見つかったらもうすぐ刑務所に入れちゃう
裁判もなし 自分の戒律を守るために
それより自分の心を強くすればどうですかね
むちゃくちゃ飲むんですよ
飲んではいけないイスラム教で
むちゃくちゃ飲む 日本にいる人々を見てください
そんなに それなのに自分たちが正しいと
いくらテキストに書いてあっても
人格ができてない できてないならば
どこかで教えがおかしいんですね
例えば女の人がもう頭上からもう足のところまで全部隠しておかなくちゃいけないんだと
なんでと これは女の人を見たら男を誘惑するんだと
なんであんたがそんなに女の体見ただけで誘惑されるんですかね
だから男の弱みはまあいいんです
それは その代わりに女の人々を苦しめなくちゃいけない
どんな教えですかね だから世界潰そう
世界潰そうと思っちゃうんですね
だから逆をブッダが教えるんです
あなたが強くなりなさいと
だから欲の場合は このある人が
ある他の宗教の人が 世の中にある美しいものは欲であるとすごい哲学的な言葉を言ったんですよ
ちょっと原文は思い出せませんだけど
ヴィチッラーニという言葉が出てきますけど
この世の中でこの美しいものというのはカーマ欲だと私は言いますよと
そこでお釈迦様の答え
世の中の美しさはカーマではありませんと
それに対してあなたの圧倒がカーマです
欲ですよと サンカッパラがプリサッスカーマ
あなたの概念 あなたの思考がカーマですよと
花がカーマ欲ですよと言わない
仏教は 花に対する自分のアプローチがカーマです
なんて美しい花ですかと
あ 持っていきたいと そこです
欲が生まれているんです
だから仏教というのは綺麗な花
美しい女性なんか潰すな
潰してくださいということじゃないんです
お金が見ると欲が生まれてくる
美味しい食べ物を見ると欲が生まれてくる
美しい人々を見ると欲が生まれてくると
美しい音楽を聞くと欲が生まれると
それ潰すんですかね その代わりに自分を心を育ててみる
聞きたくない音が耳に入っても
ものすごい美しい音が耳に入っても
何のことなく平安な心でいられるように
自己を育てて強くする
それ自体が平和なんですよ
だから仏教で平和の教えと看板は持ってないんです
看板を持つのは恐ろしい人々なんです
この世の中で平和の看板を持った人はみんな戦争を起こしちゃったんです
で 仏教はじりじりと真理を語っていくんです
嘘だったら証拠を言ってみなさいと
間違ってるんだったら言ってみなさい
みんなに自由さえ与えているんです
これは神の言葉だから信じなさいということはまるっきりない
反論してみなさい 納得いかないんだったら
どうぞもう調べてみてください
仏教は偉大なる自信を持っています
語っているのは当たり前の事実
だから仏教というのは
理性ある人であるならば
絶対神々にも人間にも
どんな智慧の人にも これが違いますよと言えません
頭狂ってると言えますけどね
それである 自分の国のことなんですけど
ある神父さんかな 新聞で記事を出して
この仏教と比較して ブッダとイエス様というところで
ブッダの教えがレベルものすごい低いんだと
イエス様の教えがすごいレベル高いんだと
理由はイエス様は神ではありません
自分が何のことなく単純な人間であることは自分で認めているのではないかと
でもイエス様は 私は神であるとはっきり言ってるんだと
だから上ですね で 最低お釈迦様は預言者でもありませんと
それ見て私は笑っちゃったんだけど
もうガキやないんじゃないかと
こいつはと だからスリランカでは宗教的なそういうのはすごく自由なんですけど
まあそんなこと言ったっても
仏教の人々は腹が立って殺してやるぞということはまるっきりない
大体返事もしません 私でも返事できますけど
なんだ ただのガキやと思ってね
笑って終わっちゃったんだけど
やっぱり誰かがそれに返事書いてあったんですよ
もう 2 3週間経ったところで
その返事読んでみたっても
いかに丁寧に書いてるかで
本当に素晴らしかったんですね
それほど立派な返事でもなかったんだけどね
でも一つ一つに答えであったんですし
もう反論できないぐらいに
で 最低預言者でもないと言ったところで
私はそれで自分が否定しているでしょう
自分の教えを 世の中で腐るほど預言者はいたでしょうに
一人もろくなことを言ってないんだから
言ってますかね だからあれが仏教から見れば精神分裂病なんですよ
何か言葉が聞こえるとか
だからこの分裂病の人々の言うのをうわごとですか
そんなものに基づいて人生設計するんですかね
だからお釈迦様ははっきりと理解した人
証拠を持ってしゃべる人の教えに基づいて人生設計しなさいよと
今も現代時代までも あっちこっちからもう神の言葉を聞いている人が現れるわ
神を目で目の前で見える人がいるわ
そんなにすごいんだったらすごいことを言ってほしいんですよ
言ってること全部なんで外れるんですかね
だから客観的なこと全部外れているということをはっきりしているんだから
イエス様というような
このユダヤ人の救済者として王様が現れると言ったのに
結局当時で現れたのに
ユダヤ人が全然相手にしなかった
殺してしまったんだから認めなかったんだから
あれほど予言があったのに
だから予言一つも合ってないんですよ
まあ頑張ってますけど
聖書はこの一つ一つ予言をちゃんと
何といいますか もうその通りに置き換んですよ
あんなものはすごい苦しい解釈であって
ノストラダムスの解釈解釈と同じなんですね
ノストラダムスという
なんか精神的な ちょっと変なことを言う詩人がいて
この世の中の人々はこれこそ予言書やと思って
ものすごい苦労して解釈するんですね
私からは一つも合ってないんですけど
なんで預言者に明確に言えないんですかね
何年何日 何年 何月何日
こういうことが起こるかとかね
例えば世界地球スケールで大危機にありますよということがね
なんで言えなかったんですか？誰一人にも
私はそのニュースをテレビで見た瞬間で
いかに世の中儚いかと
瞬時に全部変わるんではないかと
この 1時間前 我々はものすごいいい機嫌で気分でいたのに
もうそのある瞬間からもう怯えなくちゃいけないと
だから一瞬先わからないというブッダの教えが正しいんじゃないですか
ですから あの方がブッダが預言者ではありませんとかね
なんとかと言っても ブッダが預言者とアホじゃないんだから
ブッダは 精神的な病気じゃないんだから
自分で研究して 自分で調べて
真理を発見した もう偉大なる知恵
偉大なる天才ということの明確ですね
我々にできることじゃありませんだから
頑張っても弱くてね それほど頑張りもしないし
まあそれだけの差ですけどね
そこでまあどんどんもっと
我々の教えの中身に入ってみたいんですけど
あの 今日たった二つの言葉をテーマにしているんです
まあほとんど皆様方知っている言葉で
サンディッティコ アカーリコという二つの言葉なんですね
このサンディッティコという言葉
サンディッティコ これがこの目の前に結果が得られるという意味なんですね
で パーリ語だから 一つの訳では全部意味は通じません
だからサンディッティカっていうのは
すぐ自分の目の前で即効性あるということな
一つの意味 ですから我々この実証というか
すぐ証拠を正しいか何かすぐわかりますよと
それでさらに解釈して
この修行しても もう百年後で
一億年後で あるいは何百億年後で結果が出るぞということは全くない
そういうことだったら
目の前の証拠はないんです
だから事実だから科学的な事実も同じことですよ
すぐその瞬時に結果が出てこないと
良くないんでしょうね
その辺でこの仏教の強さというかね
なんで私でもすごい もうすごいものすごい強く喋りますけど
これもともと強いんです
恐怖感とか怯えとかもあるひとかけらもない世界なんです
脅しっていうのは全くない
チャレンジはあります
チャレンジと脅しっていうのはまるっきり違いますから
ですから強くやってみなさいよと
すぐ結果が出ますよと
ですからやってみなさいと
エイヒパッシコという言葉もあります
こういうのは法の特色で
エイヒ来てちょうだい
パッシコ やってみなさい
見てみなさい どうかと
それはチャレンジなんです
脅しではありません これがやらなかったら
あなたはこれこれぐらい不幸になりますよとかね
永遠の何とかになりますよということはありません
仏教では永遠という言葉さえもないんだからね
すべては変化していくんだからね
変化しなかったら永遠な地獄も地獄ではありませんよ
だって火があっても燃えませんだから
燃えたっても焼けませんだから
だから 例えば地獄が苦しみというならば
日々燃えて日々苦しめなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから そういうのはもう真理わからないから言うことであって
すべて無常ですから とにかく脅しはありません
その代わりにエイヒパッシコ
カムアンドシー カムアンドトライ
やってみてくださいと
束縛はないんだから 嫌だったらいつ帰ったってもいいんです
でも 仏教に入った人は一度も理解した人は帰ったことはありません
誤解している人々はもう出て行きますけどね
自分の主観にチャレンジ
攻撃された瞬間でも帰っちゃうんです
でない限りは まあ誰でもまあ変えたわけじゃない
なぜかというと 試してみれば本当にその通りで
自分が幸せになるんだということが見えてくるんです
サンリッティコーということは
すぐ結果が出てくる 証拠がある実証的なもので
その場で証拠を一言葉一言葉
証拠と一緒なんですね
とアカーリコという 2番目の言葉
アカーリコというのは
この真理がある時空関係にのみ通用するということはありませんという意味なんです
で 我々知っているすべてのものは時空関係の中なんですよ
それはわからないで喋ってるんです
だから問題が来るんですよ
例えば寿司ございますね
寿司がおいしいですかと聞いたらそうですよと
でも寿司がおいしいですよという言葉が論理的に間違ってるんです
寿司がおいしいなのは
ある時空関係の中なんです
寿司がおいしいですよと言って
私は今日 じゃあそうですか言って
コンビニで寿司買う 買って忘れちゃって
1週間経ったところで食べようとしたらでもおいしいんですかね
だからそれもやっぱり時空関係なんですよ
あんたってすごい綺麗な人ですねと
我々何のことなく言うでしょ
でも何のこと まあ言葉はそんなにややこしく喋れませんから
それでいいんですが 我々でもそれが事実を語っているわけじゃないんです
人が綺麗ということも
その条件の中で綺麗なんです
条件変えちゃうとそれは変わってしまうんです
ですから この人類の言葉の使い方はほとんどそういう
この何て言いますか スタティックで
スタティックと言えばいいんですかね
ダイナミックではありません
まあ動的ではありませんね
すべてのものは動的なんです
ダイナミックなんです
ですから 言葉も動的でなきゃいけませんが
言葉っていうのは一つのラベルだから
これが変わらないんですよ
だって ある入れ物に砂糖を入れて砂糖ともうラベルをつけるでしょうに
砂糖が誰か使って何も空になっても
ラベルそのまんまなんです
誰が砂糖の代わりに何か他の胡椒を入れたっても
ラベルというのは砂糖ですということになっちゃうんですよ
この単語にはその問題があるんですよ
言葉には だからそれも仏教はすごい気にするんです
普通の人は全然気にしません
なぜ気にするかというと
そのこの動的な世界にスタティック
もう何か日本語ありますかね
静的な単語を言葉を使うと
それだけでむちゃくちゃになるんですね
トラブル ですよ で ソ連がとんでもない悪い国やと思っていたでしょ
今味方でしょ ですから
この例えば人のやつ あの人は悪い人ですよと言葉つけちゃうと
その言葉を本に書くと
それは静的な言葉になっちゃいますね
でも あの人はということは動的なもので
瞬時に瞬時に瞬間瞬間変わっていくんですね
ですから どんなものにも本当は言葉は当てはめることはかなりきつくて難しいんです
でも 人間がものすごい言葉に引っかかっているんです
初めからの言葉ありきですからね
それはちょっとおかしいんです
ですから この特にこの私たちは互いに喧嘩したり
戦争を起こしたり 人に対してものすごい間違っているような意見を持ったりするんですけど
これどうにもならん状態になっているのは
我々は言葉に引っかかっているんだからなんです
例えば 親戚の家に訪ねていく
親戚はあまりありがたがらなかったと
それでやっぱりこの親戚は良くないんだと
言葉で決める 接待はしなかったと
歓迎しなかったと そこで言葉にした途端
もうもう何て言いますか
その何々親戚がもうこちらとは全く機嫌が悪くて
仲が悪くて もう接待もしない行儀も悪い親戚やってことを決めつけちゃうんですね
それから その親戚の家族に対して
こちらでありったけの怒り
憎しみが動的なこと感情だから生まれていくんです
その動的な感情は この静的な言葉から生まれてくるんですよ
でも 自分が親戚の家に訪ねたって
その親戚自体も動的なんですよ
その日で何か出来事が起きたりしてね
何かの状況があって 訪ねてきた親戚を歓迎することはできなかった可能性はあります
だからそれは理解しない
そういうわけで この我々はいろんなものに言葉をつけちゃって
それからもういろんな苦しみを味わっている
だから何一つも静的なもの
スタティックなものはないと
ありえないと という因果法則を語るんですよ
条件論理 因と縁の論理
それを否定できますかね
人間には 因縁論では間違っていると
だからそれがわかると
我々にはもっと楽に生きていられますよ
自分に対して人が怒っても
あ 今の瞬間でしょうと
今の条件の中でしょうと
条件条件変われば全部変わってしまうと
だから気にするな 運ぶ必要ない
だからこの仏教のこの煩悩の中で我々が使う一言葉あって
この執着という言葉がございますね
執着ということは もっと違う言葉に入れるかと
運ぶ ずっと 運んでいるつもりです
我々何も運んでいないんです
あれは幻覚ですよ 例えば何々さんがもう悪人やというふうに頭に言葉で入れて
その何々さん悪人ということを
その言葉と感情を持ち続ける
でも結局それ空っぽなんですよ
その人というのはずっと変化していくんだから
だから運べない 人が私に対して怒ったとします
その瞬間だけのことなんです
それで私はその人に対する怒りというのは運ぶんです
永遠に 怒ったのはたった 5 分かもしれませんだけど
それに対して私の心に生まれた怒りを
私は死ぬまで持ち運ぶ
死ぬまで持ち運べないんだから
いつでも思い出して怒りを新しく作る
古い怒りから新しい怒りを作る
どんどんそうすると変わるんですよ
植物でも何でも種から植えて
それからまた種取って植えて植えていっちゃうと変化していくでしょうに
だから元の怒りとはまるっきり違う怒りになってくるんですよ
5  6年経つと それがあまりも恐ろしい世界
あまりにもバカバカらしい世界
我々は何か意見 概念 感情を持っているつもりなんですけど
それ自体が空っぽで幻覚やと
目覚めてみなさいよと見たらすぐ楽になります
すべて消えます あの妄想の世界
人を憎しみなくなります
それだけじゃなくて 人に対してすごく愛着することもなくなってしまいます
なんてかわいい人ですかと
この人と一生でももう一緒にいられるんだそうとかね
ただ頭狂うまで欲情が出てくるでしょうに
そんな生まれません 今の瞬間だけやと
次の瞬間 また別やと そういうことで
お釈迦様が厳密に無常
ダイナミズムを教えているんです
だからダイナミズムと無常ということがすべて瞬間瞬間変化するんだということは
それほど隠れているものではありません
神の秘密ではありません
神のみ知っている秘密では何もありません
世の中の事実なんです
だからこのこれを 3時ぐらいで始めたんですけど
講義はね 今 4時 ピョンヤンです
まあ 2時  4時 28分になっています
で 1時間半経ってますね
周りを見てください 思い出してください
2時のこと どれぐらい変わってるか
世界が 皆様のことを見てください
2時時の皆様の体の心の状況と 1
時間半経った今の体の心の状況とどうでしょうかと
いかに変化していっているかと
だから無常というのは神のみ知っている秘密ではありません
どんなアホでも知っている事実なんです
ただ気がつかないだけ
それに気づいたらすぐ即効性見えてきます
人間が私はこの子の宗教だ
私は何々人だ 何々国民だとかね
私は金持ちだ 貧乏だ 頭のいい人やとか
そういうもうあり得ない
あり得もしない静的なステティックな思考で苦しんで苦しんで
他を憎んで 他を他に対してものすごい愛着執着を作ったりして
もの身近な人生っていうのは地獄にして生きているんですよ
それでこの無常ということを理解してみてください
すぐその瞬間から すべての頭の中にあったあの静的な概念すべて
なんかそう言っちゃうとおかしおかしく考えちゃいますから
いわゆるステティックな概念というのはすべて消えてしまうんでしょう
だから自分自分という考え方さえも
ずっと自分と自分自分という言葉
この言葉も問題ですよ
言葉 砂糖の入れ物は砂糖の代わりに胡椒を入れたっても
ラベルはラベルだから
砂糖だから だから自分というラベルをつけちゃって
赤ちゃんの時 我々は死ぬまで自分というラベルが来ているんです
中身が違うんですよ 瞬間瞬間
だからラベル変えないんだから問題なんです
そこで無常をわかっている人が
この自分という その態度も
飛ぶんですよ なんだ バカバカらしいではないか
瞬間でしょう 花火のようなもんですよ
瞬間だけの美しさなんです
次に全く違うもの 花火はポーンと爆発して
すごい綺麗な模様を作って
次の瞬間でもう空気汚染している
暗い煙のみ あの暗い 暗い臭いでしょうし
火薬だから その暗い煙と花火を比べてみてください
いかに違うかと すべてのものはそういうふうに変化しているんだ
だからお釈迦様おっしゃっている無常という真理をちょっと目覚めて見た瞬間から
一切の苦しみというものがすぐ落ちてしまいます
そこで徹底した平和っていうのは成り立ちます
涅槃というのは我々安らぎと解釈しますね
心の平安と訳せますよ
だから心の平安があれば
社会的な平安というのはもう何のことないでしょうに
平和のために戦うバカが成り立たないでしょうに
自分の心を平安にすれば
もうすべて平安なんです
で まあそういうことで
まあ仏教には阿迦梨と言うんです
少々皆さんは疲れているようですから
ちょっと 10 分ぐらい休憩いたします
で あの まあ現代の方々はね
大体まあインスタントが好きでしょうしね
で もう 1 分でご飯を食べれば大変ありがたいということで
1 分チンして食べるご飯もあるしね
で まあこういうあのインスタント主義っていうのは
まあそれ食べ物の場合があまりよくいいわけじゃないんだけど
心の場合はやっぱりインスタントの方がいいというのは仏教の立場なんですね
心っていうのはすっごい早く変わるもんなんですよ
体っていうのは変わるためには時間がかかります
薬飲んでも それはもう血液に入って効き目効いてくるまでは時間がかかります
で すぐ変わるってことはないんですね
体が時間取りますけど
心は時間取りません 我々のは怒るために
泣くために ほんの 1 秒でも十分です
何かにそれなりのものに出会ったら
すぐ 泣いたり悲しがったり怒ったりします
例えば 怖くなるためにどれぐらいの時間かかりますかと 1
秒もかかりませんよ そういう怖くなる現象に出会ったら
その瞬間でもう怖くなるんです
例えば 怖さ感じるために映画なんか見ている場合は
もう 1時間ぐらいもっとかかるんですよ
ずっと見て見て見て見て
ゆっくりと心の感情を高ぶってもらって
それでかいまして怖くなるとかね
それがもう妄想の世界でそうなんですけど
実際はそうじゃない いくらわいわいと楽しくこのハイキングで行くとしますね
弁当持って みんなで歌いながら行くと
突然クマがよく行ったりしたら
その瞬間でもう全部終わりですよ
あの楽しみが  1 秒もかかりません
心変わるためには それで楽しいも何もなくて
クマの姿を見えた瞬間でもう怯えちゃって
もう怖くなって体が震えて
だから心変わるためには時間かかりません
なんで我々はそんなにももう健康もおかしながら
それほど世界をインスタントにしているんでしょうかね
そんなにも物事を早く
動く必要はありますかね
新幹線のスピード足らないんだから
のぞみを作って それもまだ足らないと思って
なんとかまた開発中でとかね
やっぱりその物質を早くするのはちょっと自然破壊でよくないんですよ
いい結果が出てこないんです
物質はゆっくり動いた方がいいんです
物質の速さで だからこの交通機関が速くなればなるほど
さらに人間が大変になってくるんですよ
さらに忙しくなる さらに暇がなくなる
で 食べ物はインスタントになればなるほど
我々はどんどん体が悪くなってしまう
だから仏教では 仏教はそんな余計な話喋ってないんだけど
なんか仏教から考えると
それは私の考え方だからね
あまりこの物質の世界をインスタントにしない方がいいんじゃないかなと
穏やかでした方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
でも心はそうじゃないんです
我々は心が早く行きたいんですよ
だからもう交通機関が速くなるように設計するんです
お腹が空いた瞬間で心が食えと言うんですよ
でも米といって それから炊飯器に入れてご飯炊くともう 45 分経ってるんだから待ちきれないんですね
心が 体は待てますよ お腹が空いた人が 45 分待っていたんだから死んじゃったんだって
絶対ありえないんです
体は待てます 心は待てません
だからインスタントの食べ物を作っておくんです
日本チンするものは今一歩になっているでしょうに
それで理解してほしいのは
この心がインスタントでしょうと
瞬間でしょうと ですから
仏教は体のために教えている教えではありません
心を上達するために 心を完全にするために
心を強くして人格を造って解脱を体験するために教えている道なんですね
だから解脱ということは
心の変化過程で起こる一つの出来事なんですね
だから体よりも心が必要なんですね
だから仏教はかかっている問題は心なんですね
ですから 当然インスタント主義なんです
変わるのは瞬時に変わるんだから
だから今から修行しておけば
死んでから天国に行くんだぞという話には
まあ仏教的ではありません
なぜならば 今日修行しておいたっても
それから死ぬまで 20年あるとすると
20 年間でどんな人間にいるんでしょうかね
わかったもんじゃないでしょうね
人殺す可能性もあるでしょうね
それでも 20年前修行したんだからといって天国に行ける
ちょっと理屈が合わないんですよ
ですから このインスタント主義っていうのは仏教なんですよ
ですから すぐ効き目があるんだよと
別に効き目が早く欲しいというふうな人間の欲望のことを言っているわけじゃなくて
当たり前 すぐ効きますよと
それも仏教から見れば当たり前のこと
心がすごい早く変化するんです
ものすごい速い ですから
今何かしたらすぐそこの結果が出てきます
で ある とにかく我々の心がすごく弱くて
主観でものすごく小さくなっちゃって
自我が強くなってしまって
それでものすごい弱くて怯えて生きてるんですよ
人間が自分というものすごいきつい考え方で生きているんだから
自分というきつい考え方がついてきちゃうと
もうただ成り立つのですよ
この生命の中で 自分というのはほんの一個の生命で
何の力も何もなくなっちゃうんですね
だからわざと自分のここ
自分がそうやって他から分離して小さく小さくなっているんです
この小さくなっていると
当然弱い 当然怯える こう例えましょう
海の一滴の水と海全体と比べてみると
一滴の水って何のこともないでしょう
その一滴の水に海は海と戦えますか？海を相手にすることできますか
だから一滴の水がほんの小さな波一つ見ただけでも怯えるんです
もし命あるならば ものすごく怖く
大きく見えちゃうんです
それが我々心でやっているんです
自分がいるんだと思って
だから人間はあまりにも小さいんですよ
小さいんだからすごく怯える
ものすごく不安 外から何が舞い上がってくるか分からないんです
他人が自分に対して何するか分からない
ものすごく怯えているんです
だから自信というのはひとかけらも人間にないんです
自信あるそうに行動する人々は
ただちょっと精神的な異常だけ
成り立たないんです で
それぐらい弱い あるともわからないほど弱い
例えば聖書 西洋思想では心っていうのはないんだよと平気で言ってるんだから
あの物質 唯物論やらね
まあ一応今の医学の世界でも心っていうものの存在は全く気にしていないでしょうに
あれは脳の機能とかね
言ったらいい人だからあるともない
わからないほど小さくなっているんです
そんな小さい心で私たちは生きているんですよ
歩いたり 座ったり 喋ったり
考えたり 仕事をしたりするのは
これものすごい もう小さな小さなこの弱い心なんですね
ですから 人間の生き方では何一つもうまくいくはずがないんです
何にチャレンジしたっても成功するはずがないんです
ですから 当たり前で 生きる上で得られるのは失敗
絶望感 無気力と言うんでしょうかね
力がないという 自分が弱いと
そういうものすごく嫌な気持ち
毎日 毎週 我々は味わっているんです
ああ どうにもならない
どうにもならないと そういう風に
きめ細かく微妙にお釈迦様は人間の苦しみを探し出すんですよ
親が死んでいる苦しみとかね
大隅にもう作物は全部流されたとかね
そういう苦しみだけ苦しみってわけじゃないんです
それはある場合もあるし
ない場合もある お金がなくなったらどうしようかと
そんなものはお金がなくなってしまう場合もあるし
全然もう死ぬまでにもなくならない
死んでからも残っている場合もありますからね
そんなものはそんな大胆に考える必要ないんです
でも大胆に考えてほしいのは
我々はすごい この瞬間瞬間生きている上で
絶望感やら無気力感やら
いつでもお手上げ状態っていうのは常に感じています
世界がもう限りなく巨大で
自分を襲っているような感じで生きているんです
皆様が服を着る時でも自由じゃないでしょうに
すごく弱くて惨めで 他人がどう思いますか？と思ってやっているでしょうに
だって日本で真夏でもちゃんと背広にネクタイ締めてコートも羽織っていくんだから
本人にとってはあれ 楽でしょうかね
中なんか蒸し風呂というかね
サウナですよ  １ 日中サウナの中にて仕事をする
それで楽しい そんなものはまあ捨てちまって
日本で随分夏にふさわしい服がありますね
なんとかね 浴衣となんとかって
え？作務衣とかね あんなものを着て仕事をすればいいのに
なんでできないんですか？自信ないでしょ
全然自信がない 会社の作務衣着て行こうと
それぐらい弱いんですよ
それが弱みなんです だから自分の体でしょうに
自分が買った服でしょうに
なのに自分好き勝手に着られない
世間 世間を気にしなくてはならないんです
世間様が命令する通りにするようになってるんです
世間様が決して自分のために命令しないんです
何の意味もない命令ですよ
会社に行く人はみんな背広を着てネクタイつけて行きなさいというのは
誰がどんなバカが何のために意味があるんですかね
そんなことは だから世間ということが悟っているわけでもないし
存在もしないし みんな個人個人だから
でも私が個人で思っているんだから
世間が存在することになっちゃうんです
それで世間 世間がかなり大きくて
自分がすごく強い だからそれで自分の自由がなくなっちゃって
言われる通りにしなくちゃいけない
会社が頭を剃りなさいと言ったら
みんな剃るしか方法ないんです
あるいは髪の毛を伸ばして
何かポニーテールみたいな
何かゴムバンドでもつけて
男性たちみんなそう来てくださいと言っちゃうと
そうするしかないんですね
だから女性の方々もものすごい神経使うでしょうに
服装と服 服に対して お化粧に対して
だからそういうことで
人間っていうのは至るところで小さいということを感じているんです
それも精神的に大変苦しいんですよ
分かってないんだけど
みんな この気楽と穏やか
楽しいと感じないんです
いろんなアクセサリーを買って
体につけて楽しく遊ぼうと思っても
あの中ですごい苦しみが回ってるんです
すごいストレス溜まってるんです
それで言いたいのはこういうこと
我々はそれぐらい弱い心で生きているんです
ですから 幸福っていうのは作ることはできません
それでお釈迦様がそんなに即効性ある教えを教えているんでしょうかと
やっぱりすぐ効き目が出てくる教えが教えているんです
それはちゃんと客観的に見てみなさいと
本当のところは 自分という主体が存在しないんだと
それは一つの幻覚に過ぎないんだと
ここは 私がいるということは一つの幻覚ですと
それが合成されて出てくる一つの現象ですと
耳から音を感じて 目から光を感じて
舌から味を感じて 体からいろんな感覚を感じて
それで私がという現象
一時的な現象が生まれるだけであって
理解してみなさい そうすると
もともとも自分という主体がないということはわかるんでしょうにと
そうすると誰に怯えるんです
それからは自分という主体がない場合
誰に怯える必要ないんです
それから怖くなる必要は何もなくなっちゃうんです
苦しみ消えちゃうんです
苦しいと言ったら 誰が苦しいんですかね
苦しいものはない 悟った人々の言葉をいつでも聞くと
この誰ということがなくなっちゃうんですね
体が痛いと言うのであって
私が痛いとは言わない
これはまあ組み立てているものやと
もうすぐ壊れていくんだよと
そういう世界で生きているんだから
何の苦しみもない 何の怯えもない
そこをすぐ あの将来ではなくて
すぐ体験してほしい それで心が弱いんだからこそ
自我があるんだからこそ
我々には欲が生まれてくる
世界が大きすぎだからね
大きくなりたいんだよ
自分も 欲が生まれてくる
それで大きくなりたいけど
ならない時は怒りが生まれてくる
そこで自分という主体
個体 実体はもともとないにも関わらずあると勘違いしているんだから
それに無知と言うんですね
無知と言うんです あると勘違いしているんだから
これ合成している現象だとわかってないんですね
そういうことだから 心には激しい病気
それは皆様方よくわかっている病気なんですよ
貪瞋痴っていうのは まあ一番わかっていないかもしれませんだけど
このむさぼりと怒りではいろんな失敗するんだと
いろんなダメージを受けているんだと
苦しんでるんだと 自殺までするでしょ
それで 欲のせいで自殺する場合もあるし
他殺する場合もあるし
怒りのせいで自殺 他殺する場合もあるでしょうし
欲のせいで怒りのせいで
もう他殺だけではなくて
大量殺人まで起こす場合あるでしょうし
欲と怒りで国と国が戦争もするでしょうに
だから我々にとってはすぐわかる苦しみです
なぜその苦しみ生まれるかというと
心のこの病気なんです
そこでサンディッティコダンモサンディッティコダンモというふうによく言うんだけど
それは何なのかと ある日
サーリプッタ尊者にあるお坊さんが聞くんですよ
また他のところでアカーリコダンモアカーリコダンモと言うんですけど
それは何なのかと もうダンマというのはニッバーナなんですよ
サンディッティコニッバーナアカーリコ
何なのかと そうするとサーリプッタ尊者の説明は
それはあの 今ある欲を今消える教えだと
今ある怒りが今消えるんだと
今ある無知が今すぐ消える方法ですからと
サンディッティが今結果が出るというんだよと
説明するんです そういうふうに
それでちょっと難しいかもしれませんだけど
こういうこと 我々には欲も今生まれるんですよ
10年前の欲で今苦しむことはないんです
もうとっくに忘れちゃったんだから
今欲が生まれる 今怒りが生まれる
今無知がある 今無知があるんだから
今私がいるんだと思っているんです
何か見ると その場で欲が生まれる
何か見るとその場で怒りが生まれる
そこで心はいつでも現在で生きている
回転しているんです 隠れてないんです
心は今汚れているんです
そこで心を直すことを今直すと
今の瞬間で じゃあ怒りが生まれないようにと直してしまう
欲が生まれないようにと直してしまう
これを見ても 私は欲を作れないということにする
これを聞いても 私は欲を作らないということをする
これを見ても私は怒りませんと
その瞬間で怒らないようにする
そこで平安を感じられると
そこで今自分という自害意識があるんだから
今苦しんでいるんだから
これ今なくそうと 自害意識は構成合成されているものだとすぐわかりましょうと
そうすると今心は平安を体験する
一回平安体験したら それからは二度と騙されません
心が 幻覚だとわかったらそれで終わりですよ
例えば蜃気楼は知らない人が見たら本当の水やと勘違いします
そしてそれを探しに行く
いくら探しても探しても
蜃気楼だから水にはたどり着きません
探せば探すほど苦しむんです
さらに喉が渇くんです
そこで水ではないとわかったら
また騙されますか？こういう風なことで蜃気楼が起きるんであって
水がないところに起こるんであって
水があるところには蜃気楼は出てこないと
その機能もこういう機能だとわかったら
何のこともない もう二度と騙されませんと
また 仏教ではこの呪いの呪い師ですか
マジシャンに例えています
世の中は心が幻覚を作る大変な鋭いマジシャンだと
だから我々にはもうないものをあるのように錯覚を起こすんだと
実際にこの頭の中 例えば音が耳に触れるんだけど
この音は音 ただ音だけですよ
その音は言葉にするのは私の頭の中なんです
その言葉に解釈するの
私の頭の中なんです 入った音は音楽にするか雑音にするかっていうのは
この頭の勝手なんです
それ自体全部幻覚世界でプロセシング世界で組み立てる世界なんですね
実際に目には何のも美しいものは映りません
ただ光の粒がぶつかってぶつかっていくだけ
それは適当に頭の中で情報を交わして
いろんな視覚というものを作るんで
いろんな場面を だから実際
私が見るものと皆様が見るものは違います
私が何を見ているかということは
私に何が見えているか
いわゆる私の頭の中で何を合成されているかということは
皆様には知り得ない 皆様は何を見ているかということを私には知り得ない
青いって何色か誰も知りませんよ
言葉でみんな知ってるんだという錯覚が起こるだけ
この色何？あ これは青い色
あ そう で終わっちゃいます
でも青いって私が何感じるか
他が何感じるかっていうことは全くもう成り立たない世界
わからない世界 そう 心っていうのは不思議に
この 何といいますか マジックを起こして起こしてるんです
それでコミュニケーションということがあるんですね
我々は互いに通じているんだと
嘘ですよ あんなもん成り立ちません
言ったことよく分かった
分かってくれたと 全然分かってないんです
こちらの言葉が耳に触れると
その人の頭の中でもうその人の勝手に妄想
概念 幻覚が起こるんですよ
それは何か私がわかりません
私が勝手にその人の顔とか反応とかいろいろ分かったと思うだけ
それでそういうからくりを明確に見たら
今見ないとわからないんですよ
音が耳に触れる瞬間で
それを見なくちゃいけないんです
音が耳に触れた時はよく聞いて喜んじゃって
それから後で修行に行くんだと
っていうのは成り立たないんです
我々は 1 秒しか生きていません
煩悩はその 1 秒で現れる
その生きている 1 秒で悟らなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 仏教はものすごいインスタント主義なんです
それでサーリプッタ尊者がそうやって貪瞋痴を
今ある貪瞋痴をなくす方法を教えているんだよと
故に今結果がすぐ即効的に即効的な教えだよと
だから一回 その幻覚のからくりを破る破る破った人にとっては
もう二度と騙すことはできない
ですから 本当の平安安らぎというんです
それが最高の安らぎ そちらに言葉がないんですよ
この平安の状態 何なのかで言葉は成り立ちませんだから
言葉の世界も破っているんだから
悟った心っていうのは人は見えませんだから
音楽は聞こえませんだから
もうそれはすべて幻覚だから
言葉も幻覚だから 一切幻覚破ったんだから
もうそれで終わり すべて言葉も人間の思考も
だからすべて一切乗り越えたところやと言うんです
でも 一切乗り越えたところ行った途端
言葉で考えちゃうと この世のものではないと感じちゃいますよ
でも この世のものなんです
今の 1 秒のことなんです
それは厳密に仏教でいう即効性のある悟りっていうか
それで皆様の実践の世界から考えてみてください
我々はヴィパッサナーという見るという目覚めて見るというのを教えています
皆様方 怒りが生まれた瞬間で
これ怒りやと自分と別にして見てください
自分と同一化しないで
これ怒りというある感情だ
見えた瞬間で消えるでしょうに
欲が現れたら 今欲という感情ですと
ああ 好きです ああ 好きですというと
もう主観的で もう幻覚の中なんですよ
ではなくて 好き 欲という感情ですと
ちょっと見てみください
見えた瞬間で消えるんです
時間かかりません 見えたと同時に消える
それ以上早いことは世の中ではありません
これが一番早いことです
普通の世界で怒りを抑えるためにどれぐらい頑張るんでしょうかね
誰かと憎しんでいるとする
その二人の憎しみをなくそうと思っちゃうと
どれぐらい説教しなくちゃいけないでしょうかね
何年も頑張るんでしょうね
だから即効性ないんです
だから誰かと誰かと別れた
腹が立ってお互いにいろいろ喧嘩したりする場合は仲直り
例えばユダヤ人とパレスチナ人の間で仲直りしてあげようと思ったらできると思いますかね
この我々ありがたがっている現代知識で
現代思考で 現代技術で
心理学でもかなり発展していると思っているでしょうに
それでポリティクスやらインターナショナルポリティクスやら
いろんな相談する ディスカッションする
会議を行う もう技術 いろいろ本いくらでもあるでしょうに
そういうものは全部勉強して
じゃあパレスチナ人とユダヤ人を仲直りしてあげると
結局無理でしょう なぜ無理かというと
そういう方法は即効性ないんです
だからこれで見てください
単純に自我がないんだと
そちらにパレスチナ人もユダヤ人も存在しないよ
それは単なる妄想やと
ですから パレスチナ人が石一つ投げちゃったらね
怒るでしょうね 怒りが生まれたと
怒りが生まれた自分の具体的な怒りを見る
あいつはパレスチナ人だ
石を投げたら まあ撃たなくちゃいけないんだとか
そんな妄想をやめて 怒りやと思ったらその瞬間で消えるでしょう
ですから 即効即効性というのはそういうもので
世俗的な生き方ではもう絶対成り立たないことで
これは智慧でもって自分を見たらすぐ消える
そうやってこの見て見て見ていくと
物事は生まれて消えている
生まれて消えて生まれて消える
えらい勝手じゃないかと
怒らない人に会っても
もう場所が変わったら怒ったりする
怒っている人でも場所が変わったら怒らないとかね
だから自我 人格とか自分とか性格とか何やと成り立たないでしょうと
皆様方は絶対他人のものを奪わないでしょ？と思ってるでしょう
人格やってそんなことないんです
もしどこかに行って 何もないところで
自分に何もないところで
もう空腹感で でも周りに誰かが何か持っていると奪わないと思いますか？その条件でやっちゃいますよ
日本人が世界一行儀はいいと思ってるでしょ？外国に行ったらどうですかね
だからそういうのは成り立たないんですよ
日本の中でそうなんですけどね
だから人格っていうのはないんです
その時その時 すぐ変わる
だからそうやってなんか変だと
これ自分がないんじゃないかと
我々は例えば女の子の仲間に入ったら
また違う人格で 男だけの仲間に入ったらまた違う人格で
電車に乗ったらまた違う人格で
そういうことを観察していくと
何やこれ 自分というのはどこにもないんじゃないかということが見えてくるんですよ
そういう智慧が現れてくると
むさぼりと怒り闘っているけど
どんどん無知も消えちゃって
智慧がパッとひらめいてくる
それから問題は全部解決します
ですから 効き目があるということは
その瞬間でもわかります
ということで この方法と結果
道と目的 私たちにはかなり時間の隔たりがあります
大学に入ったら四年間の勉強と最後に卒業やと
そうやって人間の世界では
この道と結果っていうのはかなり時間
隔たりがあるものなんです
仏教というのはそれを一つなんですね
一緒になっているんです
隔たりがない そこなんですね
この道元さんのこの曹洞宗のね
まあ思考で もう彼は頭ばっかり働かせていた人で
この悟りと修行と悟りというのは一緒というふうなことを言ってますけど
それをまた妄想で解釈してされたそれでそれも間違っているんですね
後で で ですからまあ座ればそれだけで悟ってるんだよとか何とか言って
修行の方法もなくなっちゃってね
大変なことになってますけど
まあ座っただけで悟って仏になるわけじゃ
ブッダになるわけではありませんし
道元はそんなこと言ってもないんですけど
解釈する人々はもう自分でもう欲に溺れてるんだから
いいことにそれをいい方向へ解釈しているんですよ
でも 全くとんでもないことを言ってるわけでもないんですよ
厳密に この今日ご飯食べたら来月満腹になりますよという話はバカバカらしい
ご飯食べると同時に満腹になっていくんですよ
それを言ってるんです
ですから ヴィパッサナーという観察方法をすればするほど
その分 その分 その分 幸福感を味わっているんです
無我感を味わっているんです
みんな何やってるか自分でもさっぱりわからない
ただ そのそれ無我感なんですよ
私が修行してるんだ 私がここまで進んでいるんだという実感があると
それはヴィパッサナー瞑想じゃないんです
だからただやっているだけ
いたずら そうするとそこでももうとっくに自分がない世界で
でもものは動いている
すべて動的だからね だから自分という主観がなくても
もう勝手に物事は動いているんだということをね
すぐわかるんでしょうね
もうちょっと頑張ればね
すぐ鼻の先にあるものですよ
この完全解脱というもの
で そこら辺は厳密に説明すると
仏教のこのすぐ結果が出るという話ね
それぐらいやと思います
あとは一般的な即的な例というのはいくらでも出せますけど
で そこら辺言うべきかないか
まあ時間の関係もあります
で あの 昨日の勉強会でも言ったエピソードなんですけど
このインドで大変有名な
ものすごいインドのもう歴史の初めからでもいたある家なんですけど
バーラッドワジャというバーラッドワジャ家族ですね
家族で言うんで 家柄ですね
このバーラッドワジャ系の人々っていうのは
バラモン人の中でももう最高級なレベルで
で ヴェーダ聖典を作った仙人たちの一人の家柄です
で あるバーラッドワジャ系の家で
奥さんがなんとなくお釈迦様に出会って話を聞いて
こんな宗教全部捨てちゃって
もう 1番目の段階で悟ってるんです
だからやっぱり幸福修行者っていうのはブッダの世界ということでね
もう確認していて でも他宗教を批判することも何もないんですよ
自分結婚した相手がバーラッドワジャ系のバラモン人で
その人の仕事はちゃんとやっている
ものすごい立派な奥様なんですね
だからそのバラモン人も
やっぱり自分の奥さんのことをすごく大事に
いい人と一緒になったって満足して
仏教の人だからね 何も何のこと問題を起こしませんし
すごい明るく元気でいるし
でもバラモン人というのは口癖で
何かいつでも呪文みたいなものを言うんですよ
宗教の世界でそういう世界だからね
彼女もそういうふうに育てられたし
だからなんとなく癖で何か言わなきゃ気が済まないんですね
何か祈り 文句か何か言わないと
オームとかね ヒーラーとかいろいろありますよ
オンナマシワヤとかね
南無妙法蓮華経とかね
ナムアミダブツとかいろいろありますよ
口ずさむ言葉っていうのは
宗教の世界でそういう癖ついちゃうと何か言わなきゃ気が済まないんですよ
でも 彼女はそういう世界はもう一切もう捨ててるんですね
そうすると もう何か起きちゃったら
何言えばいいかなとわからなくなっちゃったんですね
例えば 浄土真宗系の方々だったら
もう死んだ人を見たら
あんなもんという習慣がありますよ
日蓮系だったら南無妙法蓮華経とか
何か言わなきゃちょっと気が済まんんですよ
怪我しちゃったら南無妙法蓮華経すぐ言っちゃうんですね
それ彼女にとってはもう何言えばいいかと何もなくなっちゃって
彼女は自分の先生に礼をナモタッサ
バゴトワラとサンマサンブッダと言うんですね
それは具体的で もうお釈迦様は本当に悟った人やと悟ったお釈迦様に礼をしますと
で 神の代わりにお釈迦様にしてしまったんです
だからもうなんかちょっと何かにぶつけたら
すぐナモタッサって言う
それであのブラマン人が困って困って
自分たちがヒンドゥー教の最高級のこのもうもう 10人ぐらいの家族かな
それぐらいの一つですよ
だからそれぐらいの立場の家の奥さんが全く自分の宗教と関係ない呪文を唱えちゃうと
やっぱり家通して困っちゃうんですよ
困るんだけど いい奥さんで何も言えないんですね
ある日 すごい行事がありまして
たくさんブラマン人が来て
この彼女を接待していたんですよ
そこで何かこぼれちゃって
こけちゃって 何のこともなくナモタッサということを言ってたんですね
だから出来事は大きい出来事だから
ちょっと大きい声で言ってしまったんです
そこで他のブラマン人たちがなんて汚らわしいことを言うんでしょうかと
全く邪教での言葉を言っているのではないか
こんな聖なる行事の時はとか
汚しちゃう 汚しちゃったんだと
で 怒ったんですね 怒っても奥さんはもうヒンドゥー教ってギシギシ儀礼男性がやっているんだから
何のことなく自分が台所の方に行ったんだけど
あのバーラドゥアージさんをさんざんやられちゃったんで
バラモン人たちに いくらなんでも自分奥さんのことはものすごく叱ったりすると
もうこれはもう腹が立ってきますね
そこまで言う必要はないや
あんた方にはと と怒ってしまって
でも行事が終わった時はまあ奥さんに当たったと思いますね
お前のせいで私はもうなんてひどい目に遭います
プライドは粉々に傷ついたのではないかとかね
ものすごい大恥かきちゃったんだよと
何をと それは このブッダを信仰することをやめてくれませんかと
言えば違うでしょうとと言われちゃって
彼女はめげません 悟っているんだから
あんたね そんなに怒ったりするよりは
私は信仰でブッダってどんな人か
一度会って話してみなさいよと
会ってみて気に入らなかったらいいやと
じゃあ そう 会ってみますと
こちらもすごい知識人で
もう勉強もうもうもう最高なレベルまで勉強しているすごい人だからね
すごく混乱状態で落ち着きがなくて
お釈迦様に対してすごい切実な態度をとっていろいろ話してるんですね
話していて とにかくお釈迦様は全然混乱もしなかったし
怒りもしなかったし 落ち着いて答えていたんですね
それでじゃあ宗教的な質問をしてしてやるぞと
あんた何か一つ言えますかと
この 何を捨てれば人は楽になるか
何を捨てれば人は心に穏やかになって平安を感じるかと
宗教家として絶対やってはいけない
絶対なくしてほしいものって何？何やと思ってますかと
すごい難しい質問をしたんですよ
一つだけ言ってくださいと
この一つが消しちゃえば
それで全て終わりという何かあったら言いなさい
言ったら お釈迦様がこの人すごく怒っているんだからね
そうですね この怒りなくしちゃえばと
私は心落ち着くと思いますよと
怒りが消えると心はすごい平安になると思いますよと
宗教として言えば この怒りというたった一つのことを絶対破滅にするべきやと言えるんだよと言った途端
あのバラモン人がびっくりしてしまっちゃうんです
すごい言葉ではないかと
本人が怒って混乱して怒りやと
これで見えちゃったんですね
見えた瞬間で消えちゃったんですよ
消えて あの一言葉ですっごく心の安らぎを感じたんです
なんてそこそういうことなんです
今まで怒りに怒って 混乱に混乱で苦しんでいた人がある日聞いた途端
安らぎを感じて ああ 並みの人じゃないんだと
やっぱりサスカジブのお坊さんがブッダにも一方的に一方通行で信頼してるのわかりますということで
でも奥さんに負けてはたまりませんだからね
だから出家しちゃったんです
出家して出家して悟ったんです
完全にお釈迦様と喧嘩しようと言って
そこで彼の弟がそれにはものすごく怒って
お釈迦様に計画を立てて侮辱してやるぞと言って
お釈迦様は家に接待したんです
食事作ってあげますと
で 食事作ってあげる計画は全くない
でお釈迦様が来たら ありったけの言葉でお釈迦様を罵倒したり
侮辱したり けなしたり
批判したりしたんです
ずっとお釈迦様は全部何のことなく聞いていたんです
聞いていて 彼の計画というのは
人にね お接待しますから来てくださいと頼んで侮辱して帰しちゃうと
その人 帰ってからも苦しいんですよ
なんであの人の家に私は行ったんですかと
こんなくだらないご飯食べるために
なんて恥ずかしいかと
そこまで計算してあったんです
それでお釈迦様 全部終わったらあなたにちょっと聞きますけど
あなたがこのあなたの親戚に豪華な料理をして接待しようとして用意したとしましょう
そうすると その親戚たちが何か用事があって家に来ない
家に来ない場合は あなたは作った料理にどうしますか？と
その場合 私は作った料理
私と私の奥さんと子供たちで食べますと
ああ そうですか なるほど
それであなたは私を招待して
今はこの侮辱とけなすという
まあそういう非難するという接待をしましたと
でも残念ながら私は受け入れられません
ですから 君と君の奥さんと子供たちを十分受け取ってくださいと
お釈迦様は何のことなくお返ししちゃったんです
全部一言も人を叱ることしないで
優しい言葉で全部返してあげたんです
その瞬間で ああ やっぱりお釈迦様には負けたと
この人は絶対怒らない人やと言って
その人も出家するんです
そういうことで バーラッド王系のほとんどの偉いバラモンたちが仏教徒になって出家しちゃったんです
だからお釈迦様はその場でその人の問題を解決する
その場で安らぎを与えてあげる
お釈迦様に反論して倒してやるぞと来る人がほとんど悟って終わっちゃうんです
その座った場で だからその現実的に今の問題を語るんだからなんです
今泣いてるんだったら
その原因をなくしてあげる
それの普遍性も教えてあげる
例えば ある人がね 自分の子供が死んだったということで頭狂っちゃって
あっちこっちどこへ行ったっても解決方法ない
お釈迦様のところに来たら
お釈迦様が彼女にやっぱりみんな死ぬんだよと教えてあげたんですね
きちんと経験させて それでなんで死ぬことみんな死ぬんだから
なんで悲しいやろうね
当たり前のことだから
だって雨が降って我々びっくりしないでしょうに
当たり前のことでしょうに
今はちょっと暗くなってるんだから
びっくりする？当たり前だから
びっくりするバカがいないでしょうに
そんなことに だから人が死ぬってことは当たり前なんですよ
なんでそれだけびっくりして悲しくなるんでしょうかね
それで あ それは心に愛着あるんだからと
そのものについては ですから
ものに愛着があると そこにあるのは悲しみだよと
だから君がどんなものにも愛着しないようにした方がすごく幸せ
楽でしょうと ああ わかりましたと
道がわかったと その場で悟るでしょう
頭は狂っていたんだけど
だからそういうふうな教えなんで
だから質的には全く他の教えとは違うんですよ
ある人がお釈迦様とものすごい喧嘩して減速して他宗教に行ってしまったんです
修行はうまくいかなかったんですね
ちょっと欲出しちゃったんです
欲出しちゃうと仏教の世界じゃないんだからね
超能力欲しかったんですね
それは仏教では禁止 欲だからね
得る世界じゃなくて捨てる世界だから
得ると苦しみがあるんですね
たとえ超能力であろうと
だからお釈迦様はちょっと道が違うとということで何も言えなかったし
本人にまた能力ないんですね
大体何か欲しがる場合は
それは能力ないんですよ
だからありがたく見えちゃうんですね
ああなりたい こうなりたい
みんなやるでしょうに
小さい時でも こういうふうになんとかなりたいとか
音楽家になりたくて必死に苦労すると
本当は才能ない だからありがたく大きく見えちゃう
才能ある人にとっては何のこともない
ごく普通なことで もう淡々と成功していきますよ
それも人間の心の悲しいところなんですよ
ないものは隣の芝生が綺麗に見えるという諺がありますね
だから もうそれは心の悲しいところですからね
だから彼に才能もないし
お釈迦様も何も知らなかった
彼が減速して他宗教に入ってお釈迦様を侮辱し始めたんです
ブッダっていうのはただの論理ばっかし
ただ論理でぺちゃぺちゃ喋ってるだけだと
口が上手だからと 何のこともないんだと
彼のところに でも彼が言う通りにやると
やっぱり効き目がありますよと
その一言葉入れるんですよ
もう彼がただの理屈ばっかり喋ってるんだけど
まあやってみると結果がないとは言えませんと
なぜかというと この人も修行し
出家して真面目に修行してみたんですね
その分 すごくいい結果があるんです
だから自分が味わった結果だから
それは否定したくないんです
だから他人があんた全く何もできなかったと聞いちゃうと
ちょっとプライドが傷つくし
ですが いえ そうでもない
頑張ってみたらそれなりに結局ありましたよと
というところも言っちゃう
それでお釈迦様の反応は
あの愚か者が私を侮辱しようとして頑張ってるんだけど
結局私を褒めているんだと
それぐらいの能力ないんだと
人を侮辱するんだったらはっきり侮辱してほしい
侮辱しようとして褒めたって意味がないしと言って
まあその場合でも やっぱりこの仏教というのは必ず結果が出る即効性あるというようなことなんですね
で それからこの 怒りに抱いていこうてはいけないと
そういうのはもう火事に火に例えていますよ
怒りが生まれたら 誰かのせいで怒ってしまえば
私がかえってかえってその人に怒ると
そうすると自分が火だから
火に薪を燃料をあげればあげるほど火が燃えるんであって
消えるわけじゃないんですね
だから怒る人に怒るなよと
欲張ったりすると逆に欲張らないと
そういうふうな教えを教えてるんですね
憎しむ自分を憎しむ人に対して
自分が憐れみをするんだと
物惜しみにはお布施しなさいと
この消す方法を教えているんですね
だから仏教では敵を倒せません
これ どれほど厳密に言っているかというと
恐ろしい犯罪者たちが来て
我々を捕ま捕まってノコギリで手足を切断するとします
生のまんまで 恐ろしい人々がもう何の悪いこともしていない自分をそうやって足をノコギリで切断する
両手を切断すると その時でも
あなたは嫌なやつらだなという嫌な気持ちさえを起こしちゃうと
それ私の道ではないと
それが私の道じゃないんだと
かすかにでも悪人に対して怒りがつくんだから
だからそれがこの理想というか
このいわゆるモデルになる例えなんですね
これはもうノコギリの例えという経典
有名な経典でね どれぐらい我々は敵に対して哀れに持つべきかということ
それ以上ひどい目には誰も会いませんだからね
で その道が間違っているという人々がいます
敵に対してどうすればいいかと
やっぱり悪人だから放っておけないと
倒すべきですよと それで悪が消えると勘違いする
例えば住人が悪い人がいる
住人殺しちゃえば それで悪が消えると思っちゃいます
それ消えません どんどん増える
だから敵を倒すべきじゃないんです
敵を哀れむんです 協力してあげて
味方にしてあげようとする
それができればやってみる
そうすると じゃあ仏教の人々っていうのは
悪い人々を野放しに野放し
野放し 野放しにするんでしょうかと
で 恐ろしい犯罪者やらテロたちやらね
野放しにするとどうなるかというと
どうせ狂ってるおかしい人々だから
どんどん被害が増えちゃいますよ
だから野放し野放しにするのも知恵じゃないんです
じゃあどうすればいいんですか？戦うことも知恵じゃない
戦う一番悪い 野放しにすると
もうあれほど戦うよりは危険ないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり危険はいくらかでも増えちゃいますね
じゃあどうすればいいかと
すごいいい言葉があります
見放す 見放したら終わり
何もできません それで自分の火で自分が燃えて終わっちゃうんです
もう一人の人に火をつけることはできません
だから智慧が見放すことなんです
なぜかというと この世の中で我々は互いに関係なくては生きていられません
もう世界的にも指名手配されているその人も
一人ででは何一つもできませんよ
みんなの協力がないと何一つもできません
それは事実です だったら見放しましょう
じゃなく そう見放す それがこの世の中の人々にできないんですね
仏教はします 例えば この何年ぐらい前かな
タイでちょっと出来事を聞いたんですよ
あるお坊さんが このまあなんか
何て言いますか 衣の上で普通の在家の人の服を着て
ある女の人に行っていたんです
ところにで そういう女性のところに行っちゃうと
それで戒律は全部無効でお坊さんではないんです
だから絶対禁止の世界
厳しいだからね 戒律が
それでその人を警察か軍隊か言って
情報入っちゃって捕まったんです
捕まってテレビでも BBC でも放映したんです
その人 捕まってすごい体格の人でも
着てる服なんか軍隊のとか全部やっぱらしちゃったんで
それで中 この頃もなかったんだけど
下の衣とか着ているんですね
だからそれだったら仏教に対しては大変な不名誉なことでしょうに
坊主っていうのはそんなもんかと
隠れて着替えて女のところに行くもんかと
ふうなことは イスラム
タイでもカトリック教とかいるし
かなり仏教に対していろんな対立しているんだけど
それは一つもできなかったんです
なぜかというと 仏教の世界はきれいにその人は見放す
お前のせいと ブッダのせいでもお坊さんたちのせいでもない
悪いのは君やと だから自分やったことの結果は自分で受けなさいよ
そういうことで 仏教の世界は何の問題もなくいまだに尊敬されています
それにかえて 今の現在の社会のことを考えちゃうと
このテロに攻撃するそうということは
イスラム人のある一人の人に攻撃することは
イスラム教に対する攻撃やと
故にイスラムの国々みんな聖戦として聖戦ですね
まあ戦うべきですよというところで
ある頭のおかしい一人の人イコールイスラム教ですよ
だからラディンがイスラムですかね
だからヘリコプターというと野放し見放しちゃえばいいのに
一人一人がどのように生きているかということは
どんな宗教にしても同じことでしょうに
あるカトリック教の人が悪いことをしたんだからといって
カトリック教が悪いんだよと言えないでしょうに
その人をもう見放しちゃえばいいでしょうに
見放すことは残酷なことじゃないんですよ
だってカトリックキリスト教から見ても
人が罪を犯しちゃったらどうしようもないんだから
それは個人の責任なんです
だから個人が勘違いしてでも
精神的な問題があってでも
何でもいいんですけど
何かしたんだからといって
この全体的な教えが責任にするのはよくないんですね
だからイスラム教のこの本当にこのタリバンというのは
もう学者でもそうですね
コーランのその人々に
このラディンイコールイスラムというのは間違っているよとわからないんですね
なんでしょうかね それは
だから我々の世界 人間の世界では一人では生きていられません
だから仏教でこの悪人というかね
どうにもならん 社会に迷惑いうことを聞いてくれません
敵を味方に回そうとしたっても
話は聞かない   もう手に及ばない
だったら見放しましょうと
見放したら もうすぐその人は一人
自分が作った木で自分で燃えて終わっちゃうんです
それは悪いことでも何でもないんですよ
悪を犯した人はどうしてもその苦を受けるんだから
その見放すということが
私はお釈迦様がおっしゃっているすごい智慧だと思います
我々には与える このすごい厳しい罰はそれなんです
まあいろいろサンガっていうのは社会で生活するでしょうし
そのいろいろ社会のサンガの社会のしきたり破ったらもう厳しいんですよ
我々は社会戒律に対してはものすごい神経質か
お坊さんたちに会う時は
もう今日でも三人だったんです
いつでもどこで誰が座るかということに対しても
ものすごい緊張するんですね
それで長老が私に前に座ってください
私はもうこれはもうダメということで
自分で座布団を持って別のところに行ったら
まあいいや それすぐわかりますから
じゃったらこちらだよと
そこでミャンマーのインドネシア人に私にお経経典あげられませんだから私はもう一人若いミャンマーのお坊さんがいて
じゃああなたこちら座って
私はこちら座りますと
二人であげてくださいと言っちゃうと順番変わるんですね
座る順番が それで言ったら
この人はいいよと決めたんだけど
またすぐもう緊張して
もう長老を真ん中にして両側座ったんです
そうするとまた順番が崩れないんですね
座る順番が  どこに座ったっても関係ないんだけど
やっぱりその小さいところでも我々はすっごく気をつける
社会の戒律だから それで破ったらどうなるかというと
罰があります どんな罰かと見放される
サンガなら勝手にしろと
それで生きていられないんです
お釈迦様は再起の時 この運転手さん
運転手っていうのはおかしいんですけどね
まあ一人いたんですよ
随分仲が良くて 友人で
まあで 再起の時 まあどこへ行ってもその人と一緒に馬車を
その人は馬の管理して連れて行くんですね
だからいつでも一緒だからね
随分お互いにまあ仲がいい
でお釈迦様出家して悟ってからは
ものすごいたくさんの人々が集めているんですね
インドにいたすべての知識人たちがそちらに集めていて
この人も後から出家したんですけど
自分にとっては全然立場がないんですね
一緒に座っていろいろ話すとかね
友達みたいに君どう？とかね
お釈迦様は一切しゃべれませんし
で ただ一人のお坊さんだから
それで本人がちょっと機嫌が悪くなっちゃったんです
お釈迦様は仲良くしてくれないんだから
それでみんなにいろんな嫌味を
今更あなた方は偉いブラマン人が出家して
お釈迦様のそばに座って話し合ったり
お釈迦様の命令を聞いたり
いろいろいたっても 私ですよ
その方と一緒から 昔から
子供頃から一緒にいたの
遊んだのは私と一緒に遊んでいたんだよと
だからもうお坊さんで言うことを聞かない
なんで私はあなた方言うことを聞く必要ありますかと
ブッダっていうのは 私と一緒にもう子供頃
もうボール遊びやらいろいろなことをした人でしょうと
でお釈迦様 これが良くないとわかっていたんだけど
やっぱり一緒に育てられた二人だから何も言えなかったし
それで亡くなる前に見放しなさいよと
その人 一言葉言って亡くなったんです
それも愛情で慈しみで言うんですよ
チャンナを見放しなさいよと
それでお坊さんたちは
まあはい わかりましたということで
何のことなく お釈迦様の最後にすべてのことをして
葬式やら それからまあもう大地潔住ということがあって
それもしたんですよ 何にもなかったように
それしてからもうお釈迦様のこういう言葉がありますからとサンガが集めて
これからチャンナ比丘をサンガからいわゆる隔離すると見放すということを決めたんです
決めて そのお坊さんのところに一人の代表者がいて
あなたにはこういう罰をお釈迦様決めたので
もう決めましたと 報告したんです
それで彼がそれはどういう罰ですか？これは見放すだけですと
あんたとしゃべりませんと
誰もあんた勝手に喋ったっていいんだけど
我々喋りませんと これから一人の比丘もあなたと喋れません
と喋ったらそれも戒律違反です
それ聞いただけで彼が必死にして倒れちゃったんです
罰を聞いただけで 倒れちゃって
何のことあとで気が付いちゃって
お釈迦様は亡くなる時でも
これぐらい私のことやっぱり考えていたんだと
自分がなんと生き方をしてきたんですかと
なんで強情で誰とも仲良くしないで生きてきたんでしょうかと言って
すぐもうしょうがない
お坊さんたちも喋ってくれないし
その罰をもう解除してくれませんし
だから必死になって一人で修行して悟ったんです
悟り開いたら自動的に解除
だから仏教の目的は悟ることだから
もう戒律はいらないということで
それでやっと解除してもらったんですね
ですから 仏教というのはいろんなどんな問題にもすごい即効的な答えを出してます
今のイスラムの方々でもほとんど貧しいでしょうし
苦しいでしょうしね だからまあラディンはイスラムではありませんし
サウジアラビアのあの金持ちの王様はイスラムではイスラム教がその人ではありませんし
みんな個人個人でしょうに
俺を殴ったんだからイスラム教を侮辱したんだよというのはとんでもない話でしょうに
もし私を人が殴ったならば
それはスマナサーラを殴ったんであって
仏教を侮辱したことではないんですね
ですから 仏教そのものを侮辱することはすごい罪であって
イスラム教を侮辱することというのはとんでもない
とんでもない良くないことであって
人が悪いことをすると何やというのは誰にでも権利があります
ですから この よく全部知ってるんだという
こういう人は 私はこのパキスタンの大統領の国民に向かって喋ったものは全部聞いていて
それからブッシュさんがね
コンケスで喋った話も全部聞いてみたんですけど
やっぱり頭が悪いなとかね
人間を幸福にする道がわかってないなとか
しょうがない 当たり前ですけどね
例えばパキスタンの大統領
あれほど苦労する必要ないでしょうに
個人が何かしたならばね
それは個人のことで 我々の偉大なイスラム教はそんなことではありません
一言で言えばそれだけのことでしょうに
アメリカはもう別に法律国家だから
決してこの無差別に法律に従わないで彼を裁くことはありませんと
彼が犯人であるならば
ちゃんと証拠を調べて
まあ裁判を起こすでしょうと
ですから 我々はもう彼が悪いことをするというならば
どうぞ調べてくださいというのは
我々の宗教を守ることやとというふうな立場で喋るべきところで
タリバンの人々もそういう態度を取るべきことであって
その知恵がない 守ってあげる守ってあげるのは意味がないんです
だから それもやっぱりこの即効性の一つの例を出したのは
この現代 今はちょっとみんなに興味ある
みんなに心配してる問題ですからね
だからやっぱり我々は悪人に対しては見放す
もう社会からもどちらから
例えば日本の社会でも
みんななんで悪いことをしないかというと
この見放す現象がありますね
ちょっとやり過ぎるところまでありますけどね
だからみんなすごい気をつけて生活しています
日本で見放すというのは
犯人じゃないんです その家族なんです
息子が人殺しちゃうと
その家族親戚 みんなもう見放しちゃうんですね
それは仏教は認めません
恐ろしいと 息子が人殺したんだからといって
お母さんはどうするんですかね
かわいそうでしょうに
まあただ とにかくそれはそれで置いておいて
この見放す現象がね 日本にあるんだから
みんなかなり他人に迷惑をかけないで
あまり悪いことをしないでよく気をつけているでしょうね
ですから それは決して恐ろしいことではありません
ですから 我々はやっぱりどうにもならない
どうしても育てることできない場合は
完全に見放しちゃうと
その一個の人が自分の自業自得で苦しんで終わるだけであって
他人には迷惑はない世界が生まれてきますね
ですから そこら辺も今の現代世界でみんな知ってるんだったら
世界がもっと幸せな世界になるだろうと思いますね
憎しんで憎しんでもう報復行為やらね
それよりは関係ない人まででもね
もうもうもう六千人以上死んじゃって
まあそれで十分でしょう
その人々の死を無駄にしないで
それが世界平和につながるならばね
いいことなんですけど
そういうことで やっぱり私たちが最後に言いたいのは
やっぱりブッダの教え
大勢のより大勢の人々が聞いて理解してね
これは宗教ではないし
ものすごいジリジリした真理
事実でしょうしね だからこの自分のためにもなるし
すべての生命のためにもなる教えですから
これからよく勉強して修行していただきたいということで話を終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます